old man took her diamonds
and tiaras by the skull
now she gets her kicks in
stephanie not in the knightsbridge
anymore so don't
play with me because you're playing with
fire
[Music]
now you've got some diamonds
[Music]
so don't you play with me
cause you're playing with fire
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
it's nine o'clock on a saturday
a regular crowd shuffles in
there's an old man sitting next to me
making love to his tonic and gin
[Music]
he said son can you play me a memory
i'm not really sure how it goes
but it's sad and it's sweet and i knew
it complete
when i was
[Music]
sing us a song tonight
well we're all in the mood for a melody
and you've got us feeling all right
[Music]
now john at the bar is a friend of mine
he gets me my drinks for free
and he's quick with a joke or to light
up your smoke
but there's some place that he'd rather
be
it says bill i believe this is killing
me
as a smile ran away from his face
but i'm sure that i could be a movie
star if i could get out of this
now paul is a real estate novelist
who never had time for a wife
and he's talking with david who's still
in the navy
and probably will be
the waitress is practicing politics
as the businessmen slowly get stoned
yes they're sharing a drink they call
loneliness
but it's better than drinking
[Music]
sing us a song you're the piano man
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
cfo of hardwood products company
scott wellman
good afternoon pierta medical products
and hardwood products employees
i want to be the first person to thank
every one of you and also all of our
employees that couldn't be here in this
room with us today
for the hard work that you guys have
been doing during this emergency
we're on the front lines fighting
covid19
and you guys are working extra hours and
putting in amazing efforts
and you're starting to make a huge
difference for the united states
every one of you has made sacrifices to
make sure that we're producing
high quality products the country needs
desperately i thank you
all from the bottom of my heart for
everything that you've been doing right
now as many of you know we're partnering
with the u.s government
to build a new factory in pittsfield the
administration has been supporting us
and our company and all of you as the
people in ways we never could have
imagined before
it has been an amazing partnership
they've made it possible for us to
quickly build a new factory it's going
to have
been built in 60 days july 1st we'll
have it open
they're allowing us to build it in that
time frame put custom equipment in it
have it ready so that we can make more
swabs that are needed
we really want to also thank the
administration for what they've done for
us
for our great company here in guilford
maine
i now would like to take a second and
announce the great man that you really
want to see
and you want to hear our president is
working endlessly and tirelessly right
now to get the american economy open
to bring manufacturing jobs back to the
united states
and to fight covid19 it is my extreme
pleasure
to call to the stage the president of
the united states
president donald
[Applause]
i'm trump and i won't forget
the men who died who gave that right to
me
and i gladly stand up next to you
and they met her still today because
there ain't no doubt i love this land
god bless the usa
thank you very much appreciate it we had
some crowd coming in i don't know you
have a lot of people up here a lot more
than people think
and they're great people and they like
trump that i can tell you
well we had
we had a lot of people we got off air
force one and we
came and the roads were packed
five deep ten deep in some case i have
to be very careful because i have the
fake news back there they'll say it was
only too deep
there were some areas where there was
only one deep and they'll end up putting
me on the front page
but we had some fantastic crowd and i
just want to thank you all you're very
special people and this is a great plant
and it's doing a phenomenal job thank
you very much appreciate it
i also want to thank scott i'm thrilled
to be back in the magnificent state of
maine as you know you treated me
very nicely in the last election 2016.
you treated me very nicely i needed the
one point now i'd like to win the whole
state could you mind please okay
maine and nebraska they cut them in half
and they say one way the other i don't
know you have the double that's okay
but uh this one we had tremendous
tremendous uh turnout and we did very
well in both parts actually
but it's a great state and we just
solved a big lobster
fisherman problem we gave 5 000
acres of water we gave you your rights
back it was taken away by the previous
administration and it was disgraceful
so with the stroke of the pen your
fisherman like me
maybe even more than you like me okay it
could be could be
but it was a great thing but uh i just
want to say hello to the hard-working
men and women of puritan
medical products great company the
incredible workers of this company have
carried on the noble tradition
of american manufacturing excellence for
more than 100 years
now our nation has turned to you as we
massively increase our unrival testing
capacity
we're at as an example 20 million
tests germany's at 4 million south korea
which you heard so much about they're
doing a good job they're at about 3
million
we're well over 20 million very shortly
will be well over 20 million tests
remember this when you have more tests
you have more cases
i say to my people every time we test
you find cases because we do more
testing
so if we have more cases if we wanted to
do testing in china
or in india or other places i promise
you there'd be more cases
but we're doing a great job with the
testing and you're doing a fantastic job
in getting out the swabs on behalf of
the entire nation i want to thank you
you're building a big addition right
alongside you know that so you're gonna
have a lot more jobs coming here
in a very short period of time puritan
is one of the only manufacturers in the
world producing the high
quality medical swaps that are crucial
for the rapid testing
and every swab you make at puritan is
proudly stamped with a beautiful phrase
made in the usa do you like that france
beautiful place
[Applause]
thanks to the testing capacity that
you're making possible our country is
reopening
and our economy is recovering like
nobody would have thought possible i
guess you all saw the news today right
it was
unbelievable earlier today was announced
that the u.s economy added 2.5 million
jobs
in may it was supposed to lose 9 million
you know
during this period transition period i
call it transition to greatness but
it's coming a little earlier than i
thought and that's okay i don't like to
be
wrong on the other side but earlier is
okay
but it was supposed to be nine million
if you watch i don't know if anybody
watches the business shows but i'm
watching this morning
and they thought it was a typographical
era because it was supposed to be nine
and before the show or during the show
they're predicting comes out the job
numbers very famous job numbers
and it comes out and 8 30 in the morning
and i'm looking forward to seeing what's
going on and turn it on and they're
predicting
no i think it's going to be more than 9
million jobs lost
during the period prior to going back up
and another one said no 8.5 no 11
no 10 you know all geniuses
and now it's 8 30 you hear a bell go off
and the woman gets it in this case and
she's going
well it's only three million jobs lost
and then a couple of seconds later she
goes wait a minute this isn't jobs loss
this is jobs gained
and it's almost 3 million jobs gained
and she thought she had a typographical
error and
what happened was incredible i mean and
the market went through it
finished very very high almost i guess
around 900 points up
and our stock market is booming and our
jobs are booming and you know you just
have to look at a place like this you
just have to get off the plane and ride
hip and you see the spirit
of maine and other places other places
it's amazing
it's amazing so we absolutely shattered
expectations and this is the largest
monthly jobs increase in american
history
americans think of that that's a long
time right
by far i think it's more than double or
about double of what our highest was
before
so this is the largest monthly job
increase in american history how about
that
and we're going to have a phenomenal
next year we're going to have a
tremendous couple of months prior to the
election on november 3rd very very
important date it's going to be a very
important election because the only
thing that can screw it up is if you get
the wrong president then they raise your
taxes
and they open up your borders so that
everybody pours into our country
coveted or non-covered you used to never
hear a covet but now we have covert to
add to the list of other things
so uh we have a wall that's over 210
miles long already going up we'll have
400 miles
400 miles by the end of the year maybe
more than that and we'll be finishing it
off very early next year with
500 miles of wall in the most
treacherous places and uh it's been an
amazing thing we have
we're setting records on our border
right now for for
holding people out we don't want people
coming in we want people coming in
through a legal process and through
merit and that's what we're doing
where they can help our country but
economists forecast that the
unemployment rate
as i said would uh be about 19 percent
and they were hoping for 20
the opponents of ours they'd rather have
things be bad so they could try and win
an election
so they were hoping it would be 20
instead it's 13
that was good that we made up a lot of
time a lot of distance
it's really great even i was surprised
by this one this was better than i
thought i thought it would be okay
but i didn't know this means we're much
ahead of schedule don't forget
that doesn't include new york new jersey
and many other states and by the way
uh your state what are you going to open
this state up
no seriously you're going to miss your
whole you know you do 40 million people
in tourism
and you have a governor that won't let
you open up what's she doing
what's she doing i don't know that much
i just know you're great people you know
what i know about maine i know you're
great people
but you have this is like you know they
say
december for tiffany's that's their big
month right
this is your time this is your big month
this is your christmas
in terms of tourism your dollars when
you how can you be closed i mean
and i see it all the time everybody
wants to have maine open so i figured i
might as well say well i'm up here
you got to get the state open governor
open your state
but a lot of you have a lot of angry
people in maine about that i mean they
think
they say what are you doing and that's a
strange one some i understand a little
bit more
but uh this one is not one that should
be closed you're missing a lot of
money and a lot of everything and a lot
of people a lot of spirit get it open
we added 1.2 million leisure and
hospitality jobs
464 000 construction jobs
424 000 education and health care
jobs 368 000 retail jobs
and listen to this one remember the
previous administration said oh
there'll not be any more manufacturing
jobs in our country i say excuse me 225
000 manufacturing jobs and that's during
a
pandemic
and we had the greatest economy in the
history of our country you know we had a
an economy the likes of which we've
never had we had almost 160 million
which
was the highest number we've ever had by
far african-american
hispanic-american asian-american the
greatest employment and
unemployment numbers we've ever had uh
greater stock market numbers and we're
very close to those numbers which is
pretty amazing that means that these
geniuses on wall street and also a lot
of people with 401ks you have 401ks
well you can only vote for trump because
otherwise those 401ks are going to be
worthless
that's a big incentive that's a big
incentive
that's a big nah well it is look it's uh
bad things the only way you're going to
end it is stupid policy because
i built it once now i'm building and
again we had to close it down we did the
right thing we closed it down we saved
millions of lives
but now we opened it up and it's opening
up to a bang we're going to have better
this next year will be better i think
than any year we've ever had
that's how i feel about it and i've been
saying it for a long time the year
coming up
america's economic comeback has begun
the next year is
set to be a year and you remember i said
it but uh
it's going to be an amazing year for you
it's going to be great your new side is
going to be open big area that you're
building
and your expansion at puritan
but i'm grateful to your leadership team
including timothy templet
scott wellman and david perkins great
people fantastic people
for welcoming us we have these are
tremendous people these are great
really loving people they're doing
something very important
when you think about what they're doing
the product is superior it's
terrific and it's made in the usa and
that's
i shouldn't tell you this but i use it
every other day
i go like this i say is that a puritan
please
no it's a great product
but we're also joined by secretary of
health
and human services alex azar hazura
great job
thank you alex and secretary of interior
david bernhardt
we just left we just left that meeting
with david bernhardt and
peter navarro who's right here peter
stand on up peter
mr congressman would you please stand up
come on
we did a thing we did a we passed a bill
together right one of the
most important things right to try do
you know what right to try is that's
where we have the most advanced
medical people in the world labs and
everything else
and labs in many cases that you work
with
and we have a case where somebody was
very sick and they go to asia they go to
europe they go all over the world
looking for a cure you know they were
terminally ill or very sick
very ill if they didn't have the money
they'd go home and die
they'd go home but we have tremendous
things coming along
and yet you have to go through a process
of testing
and i said when we have a situation
where somebody's terminally ill or in
that category
we want a right to try our labs they
shouldn't have to go to europe and asia
they shouldn't have to go to all over
the world to look for a cure
and we call it the right to try you have
a right andrews complex because the drug
companies didn't want it because of
liability the country didn't want it
because they didn't want to get sued the
insurance companies didn't want it the
labs didn't want it because
they didn't want to have anything bad
happen to them in terms of what they had
to put on so
you know on their on their schedule so
we said right to try
so they have the right to try they sign
a document they waive the liability
the results i don't know if you know but
the results have been unbelievable
the results have been absolutely
unbelievable i mean we've had some great
things so
wait one of the many things we've done
but every person here today is playing a
vital role in the greatest national
industrial mobilization since world war
ii we've marshaled the full power of the
us government and u.s industry to defeat
the invisible
enemy and it is indeed an enemy
should have been stopped in china came
from china should have been stopped in
china they didn't do that
we've delivered over 1.5 billion pieces
of personal protective equipment to
doctors and nurses on the front lines
we slashed a red tape to speed the
development of vaccines our vaccines are
coming along incredibly well
well you see and therapeutics
and we partnered private sector leaders
such as puritan to build the largest and
most advanced
testing capacity on the face of the
earth
like this one at the single factory you
quickly ramped up production to produce
nearly 20 million
foam tip swabs each month
then in april my administration invoked
the defense production act to help you
scale up even more
under a 75 million dollar public-private
partnership
puritan will soon double production to
40 million swabs for a month that's a
lot
that's a lot that's why we're beating
the world
and ultimately you'll triple production
to an astounding
60 million swabs a month an amazing
achievement
of american industrial strength to
accomplish this tremendous
increase you partnered with another
legendary maine institution
you've never heard of this i'm sure bath
iron works right
builder of some of the most powerful
warships in the united states navy for
over 135 years they do a great job under
the defense production act bath iron
works is now producing
the complex machinery you need to
manufacture tens of millions more swabs
and we're all profoundly grateful to the
amazing workers at bath shipyard and the
executives they're really working very
closely in many ways including the
building of ships
here at puritan you've already hired 200
new employees with full benefits
and when your new 95 000 square foot
factory
in pittsfield comes online puritan will
hire an additional 150
maine workers made in the usa right
powered by the dedication of the men and
women in this room
america has become the world leader in
coronavirus testing
the united states has completed more
than 19 million tests
the most anywhere in the world by far as
i said you're now over 20
21 almost thanks you our country has
conducted more tests
than all other countries in the world
combined other than that you're not
doing very well
now if you listen to the fake news it's
like well you know i give him a number
we did 20 million why didn't you do 40.
trump should have done 40.
if we did 40 that they should have done
a hundred hey
yeah what i have to put up
and you know when we took over the
cupboards were empty i always say the
cupboards
meaning the stockpile we had very little
and we became now the king of
ventilators also we'll have to talk to
purity you want to make some ventilators
we don't need them
we're making thousands a week we have 11
factories plants we had
practically none and we saved thousands
and thousands of lives
ventilators are very hard because
they're big they're expensive i say it's
like making a car in a certain way high
technology
right and uh we're now making thousands
of
ventilators a week and we are uh at a
point where
we're actually helping other countries
we're sending ventilators to
other countries nigeria 200 ventilators
and then they called
we sent them 800 we have a thousand
going to nigeria italy
france spain many many
countries russia was sending some to
russia
it's good for relationship it's good for
everything and we're knocking them out
and you know people aren't able to just
you can do a swab even though it's not
that easy
but a ventilator takes a long time it's
the greatest mobilization as it said i
mean
greatest since world war ii it's been
really amazing
and uh i'd love the people of the
administration but i'd also like
to have our people that work on it even
our the people of our country to get
credit for these things you know we got
geared up we did so well that you heard
about ventilators
there hasn't been one person in the
entire country from the beginning of
this horrible
plague that came in the plague it's what
it is
there hasn't been one person that needed
a ventilator
that didn't get it and we started off
from
a very low platform they needed
desperately
thousands and thousands of ventilators
but when you think of it not one person
with all of the size of our country and
all of the people that were sick
not one person not one that needed a
ventilator didn't get i think it's an
incredible achievement to
mike pence to all of the people that
work in the administration and to all of
the people that
went and worked so hard to produce
amazing and the testing the same thing
we get whether it's abbott laboratories
or
any of the many plants roach we have uh
this incredible testing capacity we
started off with
zilch nothing so they've done a
fantastic job the whole team has done a
really great job peter wouldn't you say
it's been very amazing
i want to take a moment to recognize
just a few of the hard-working
patriots and that's why they are of
maine who
were instrumental in this colossal
effort that you've done at puritan
angie boucher where is angie
come on angie come on up here she's an
operator in puritan's laboratory kit
manufacturing
area where she's been working 10 hours a
day
seven days a week for the health of our
nation she's highly respected
i think she's very good maybe i should
hire her let's bring her back let's
bring her back to
washington please say a few words please
i have worked at puritan for the past 21
years
since the coronavirus hit we have spent
every day making millions of swabs
that help save lives
and help people save the world i am so
grateful to this company
and for the chance to serve our country
that the best way we can pay back is to
work harder
ever since the president started us
helping us grow
we have been so happy and excited to
produce
even more that i don't want to stop
until the job is done the president
has done so much to support us
and we are all so grateful to know
he is fighting for us thank you for your
leadership mr
president
thank you very much honey let's let's
take a picture come on get over here
thank you
i'm not supposed to do that but it's
what am i gonna do say angie don't do
that aren't you
thank you very much great job angie
we're also joined by tracy porter
he has worked here at puritan for over
40 years
and he's your lead tipping and packaging
technician tracy come on up and say a
few words please tracy
40 years
[Applause]
looks too young to say 40 years i can
tell you
fantastic thank you mr president
actually it was
31 years out there was a mistake but
that's funny
yeah we all mess up i feel better if i'm
looking at you
oh i appreciate that thank you
more often than not when we see news of
a crisis in the world we uh
we lament that few of us have any chance
of changing the outcome
today we find ourselves blessed with
this opportunity to make a difference
during this recent push to make medical
products we've seen
received many letters of thanks from
all around the country and kind words of
encouragement from our local community
just prior to this tragic outbreak we
were already working long hours
filling orders for customers who've been
very good to us customers like becton
dickinson
holagic and cordell just to name a few
a lot of my co-workers and i were
expecting a wish for more machines
so we could fill orders faster and maybe
keep our customers
price down well it looks like we're
going to have enough equipment now
we look forward to working with two
great main companies like chimbro
construction
and bath iron works and i want to thank
you mr president
for making it all come together
great job thank you very much even 31
years he's a
long good head of harry's got two
good head of hair you have
thank you tracy keep looking good
keep looking good keep healthy everybody
in here keep healthy
with us as well as derek mckinney the
senior manufacturing engineer at puritan
and a project manager for the new
manufacturing plant which is a big deal
coming online derek please come up and
say a few words
[Applause]
good afternoon i'm derek mckenney senior
manufacturing engineer and
second generation employee of hardwood
and puritan medical products
um my mother's been with the company for
35 years
um and i spent my childhood
[Applause]
um that's really your mother that's my
mother
uh
i spent my childhood
i spent my childhood playing in our
office so i i've been around since about
kindergarten
um i was lucky enough to be able to go
gain education
and experience um across the u.s before
returning to my roots here in guildford
maine in the last three years i've been
presented with many
amazing opportunities to make a
difference in the world with puritan's
critical products
but nothing compared to that day on
march 12th
when we got the call from the white
house task force
from that day forward i've been part of
a team who's chosen to rise up
and serve their country and the american
people
we have worked tirelessly around the
clock and through the weekends
for the last 12 weeks to provide the
testing supplies required
to keep americans safe on july 1st
we'll start production at our second
manufacturing facility
with the ability to produce 60 million
covered swabs
per month
[Applause]
this project would normally take 18
months to complete
but in a truly unimaginable feat it will
be operational
in eight weeks it wouldn't be possible
without the total and complete support
of the federal government
and the dedication of the phenomenal
workforce here in the great state of
maine
this company and all these people are
what make the united states of america
the greatest country in the world
god bless you all
[Applause]
did he do a good job mom uh i think he
did
he'll be running for office next year
thank you very much derek appreciate it
great job
and thank you all the remarkable testing
capacity that
each of you has made possible it's not
only helping our nation to defeat the
virus that horrible horrible
terrible disgusting angry virus
it's paving the way to get america
safely and responsibly
back open for business and that's what
we're doing right now we're doing it
right now it's happening very quickly a
lot quicker than people thought
a strategy for a phased and gradual
reopening
protects our most vulnerable citizens
and you know who they are
we've learned a lot about that
especially in the nursing homes while
allowing younger and healthier americans
to
get safely back to work and go to school
i think in the fall you're going to see
the schools all open and
in great shape the best approach to
protect the health of our citizens is to
focus our
resources on safeguarding those at
highest risk
while allowing those at lowest risk to
go and resume
economic activity including education
a key element of our effort to reopen
revitalize and rebuild america greater
than ever before
is bringing critical industries back to
our shores
as the workers of maine know well and
that's for many decades washington
politicians shipped away your jobs
outsourced your supply chains and
offshored your industry it's probably
the number one reason i'm here today
although i was going to say another
politician probably they wouldn't be
here they wouldn't bother with it to me
it's very important i had a savior
fishing industry so easy so easy to do
if you want to do it
but we uh we really talked about this
for a long time
our companies would leave us they'd fire
everybody pay no taxes they'd go to
another country
that make the product they sell it into
our country with no tax no nothing
well we ended up with no jobs empty
buildings empty factories you had them
in maine all over the place
but we're changing all of that we've
made tremendous trade deals now
tremendous trade deals the u.s mexico
canada deal is an incredible deal
incredible deal for our country and many
other deals we just signed a deal with
china but unfortunately in that case the
ink wasn't even dry and all of a sudden
the plague came
in and so i view it a little bit
differently perhaps but they've been
living up to the deal
they're buying a lot of a lot of things
they never had any
deal they just came in and took
advantage of the united states took out
hundreds of billions of dollars a year
so they don't do that anymore
but it's a terrible thing that happened
but as the global pandemic has shown
once and for all the united states must
produce essential equipment supplies
pharmaceuticals and technologies for
ourselves that we cannot rely on
china and all of these other countries
that in bad times
take advantage of us and rip us off we
don't do that anymore we're
moving things back into our country
that's why the united states is now
engaged in a great national effort to
bring industries factories and jobs
back to america where they belong we
want to back here
just like you're doing it we have other
other places all over the country
of course they're not as good as puritan
but they're pretty good
and i'm committed to ensuring that our
country will be
the world's premier pharmacy it's going
to be a pharmacy
drug store and medical manufacturer
we don't make our medical products here
we don't make our drugs here that we
need our desperately needed
prescription drugs or otherwise in my
administration
we live by two simple rules buy american
and
hire american
[Applause]
so just an ending i mean i say for
centuries the people of this great state
have
fished the oceans and farmed the fields
and worked the factories that have
supplied
and sustained our nation and then they
went through a very bad time
very bad time right here in guildford
generations of proud maine patriots have
poured out their
heart sweat and soul for this country
making the critical products produced by
puritan and now puritan's doing better
than it's ever done i guess by a factor
of a lot right
right you know they call themselves
associates
say in the old days they'd say they were
the boss now their associates are very
smart
that's very smart but they've done a
great job as associates you're all
associates
each of you now carries on this
extraordinary legacy and exceptional
heritage serving our nation
at this very historic time this is a
historic time
this is a very important time for our
country
you see what's going on but a lot of
good things are going on a lot of things
are going on
very big thing happened though today
when we saw numbers the likes of which
we've never seen in the history of our
country good timing
because people look at that and they say
hey this country's great we've done
things that nobody else has ever done it
was good just
good that they see that right good
timing you and your families are making
momentous contributions to the vitality
of our country helping us reopen rebuild
and most importantly
saving lives the workers of maine have
always been loyal to america and while
i'm your president this government will
always be
loyal to you just ask your fishing
industry how's trump doing because they
can't even believe what happened today
5 000 square miles of ocean
that you couldn't touch they just wrote
it off
president obama he signed you couldn't
use it anymore
they took it away i gave it back
with your help
[Applause]
by the way i said why'd they take it
away nobody knew you know it's okay to
take it away if it
means something i mean but nobody knew
with your help we will vanquish the
virus
we will get our nation back to work and
we shall build our glorious future
with american hands american grit and
american pride
and i want to just thank all of you for
being here you're very special people
this is a very special place
and it's a great state and thank you
very much and get that other half by the
way get that other half to go with trump
okay
you you i don't have to worry about and
i think they'll be there too because
there's a very very important election
coming up
the most important it's amazing what's
happened and you've been a big part of
it thank you very much congratulations
to everybody thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you